hey guys Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update CD Projekt has
responded to allegations that a member
of The Witcher 3 dev team has been
misleading the public about the
development of the game a user on NeoGAF
has said that the developer of Witcher 3
CD Projekt RED has built an overblown
impression of the game neogaf
administrator claimed they had been
vetted and cleared so there's possibly
some validity to these statements the
user was upset with people quote
painting CD Projekt RED is some magical
deb studio with only the best interests
of gamers in mind trust me they are not
he continued the bullshitting with the
witcher 3 started from day one PR is
creating an overblown vision of a game
that doesn't exist while the team is in
a crazy crunch time for over a year now
a spokesperson for CD Projekt RED
responded to these comments in a
statement to gamespot he said if you
have any doubts about wild hunts quality
have a look at the 35 minute gameplay
video we published some time ago or
check out gamers reactions to our public
previews and decide for yourself CD
Projekt RED was asked specifically by
gamespot if the studio wanted to address
claims that its team had been crunching
an industry term for working for an
unreasonable and unhealthy amount of
time in the office for more than a year
the studio did not respond to this
request The Witcher 3 does have some
crazy expectations built up for it and I
guess we won't really find out if
they're true or not until februari more
Witcher 3 news stay tuned to gamespot
com